the woman you married she had to be some
spectacular woman who really gets you I
met her many years earlier I was uh in
Israel at um
for the uh Inglorious Bastards uh
premiere uh in uh in Tel Aviv and so I I
met her I met her on a club frankly hmm
we danced all night long we danced for
three hours
I mean I had to throw my shirt away all
right when it was over because it was
just stained right like a horse dying
all right you know uh I had to throw it
away did you know she was the one that
night did you think well I'd be it I had
never had that kind of evening before I
had had really good evenings but never
that evening and she's just
she's a [ __ ] knockout I mean just
right She's a Beauty and
um and then yeah and and also her her
father is like the most famous pop
singer in Israel savika pick and so
everybody knows who she is she grew up
in the spotlight so she's like a
princess wow but we just let it drift
away and she went on and lived her life
and I went on and lived mine and then um
how do you do that when you meet someone
that great doesn't it drive you crazy
that she might meet someone else and
that that that you'll lose her forever
look I might have been a scared little
chicken [ __ ] all right right so then I I
end up going on I get invited on this
cruise and so I go on this cruise this
is like six years later
I go on this cruise and then I uh uh
meet a woman who's on the cruise who's a
family friend
of the picks which is her name and uh
she goes oh hey I'm a uh I'm a good
friend of uh Daniela and I go oh
Daniella she was so great she was so
great as if she's dead
so I just say a bunch of nice things
figuring okay I'll say a bunch of oh
Daniel it's so wonderful she was so
great I figured I'll just say a bunch of
nice things this friend will go back
home to Tel Aviv we'll we'll eventually
bump into Daniella and say hey I bumped
into Quentin and he said a bunch of nice
things about you that that was the plan
right that was the plan
well she went up into her State room and
called Daniella
oh wow and she goes so I just got
through talking to Daniella and it turns
out she just broke up with her boyfriend
so when you're through with your cruise
and you get back home
give down your little call yeah and uh I
called her we had a really nice
conversation she was happy to hear from
me and then all of a sudden next thing I
know we we talked about three different
times you know uh uh fairly shortly in a
row which is unusual for me and we
decide well okay well let's get together
let's get there and no promises we don't
know what's going to happen but right
I'm intrigued enough and I would love to
see you uh uh let's do it and so we said
okay look you shouldn't have to come to
America and I shouldn't have to come to
uh uh Tel Aviv so let's uh
let's meet in Paris I guess kind of
gearing it to work out all right uh
meeting in the city I like how you're
thinking yeah and uh but we kind of
wanted it to work out and uh so uh we
both went to uh we both went to uh Paris
and we've been together ever since